great very good okay let's let's get
started then
so it's a great pleasure to have
aleister urquharts
speaking for the second speaker today
he's a professor of philosophy and
computer science
at the university of toronto he's worked
extensively
improve complexity among many other
topics to this audience he may be
best known for his work on the same
topologies
and it's a great pleasure to have him
here so he's speaking on symmetric
properties and boolean complexity
so alistair thank you thank you sam
and thank you for the invitation uh this
is my
first zoom talk so uh so i apologize if
there's some
glitches but
thank you to sam and omid for help with
this
um
the question i'm talking about today is
is actually kind of ancient history
um it goes back to uh
an attempt to prove p not equal to np
that was about
a bit over a decade ago
and the attempt failed the proof was
was incorrect but the discussion which
followed on the internet
which went on for a while
i think it had interesting interesting
consequences and i want to
want to talk about that for one thing i
think
one of the upshots of this was it it's a
kind of barrier
that the attempt that was used which was
essentially trying to prove
p is not equal to np by using the fact
that the solution space
of uh satisfiability in this case was
complicated
this attempt i think any such attempt is
is doomed to failure
because it uses a symmetric property
so that's that's basically what what i
think we're talking about here is
is a a kind of barrier we know that
there's barriers involving
natural proofs and diagonalization and
there's various arguments showing that
these are barriers but
this is a i think a barrier that is
i think not everyone recognizes this as
being a barrier so that's what i'm going
to
talk about
so the the attempt that was made
in 2010 was by
vinnie d laliker
he was at hp research labs it was i
guess he's still that hp research labs
anyway it was it was a very clever
attempt at proving
p not equal to np uh it brought together
a number of different areas
including statistical physics
finite model theory and other
other areas in related to computer
science
but ultimately it it failed the the
the proof didn't work um
but unlike a lot of other attempts at
proving p not equal to np and p
equals mp and all these kind of things
unlike those
i i think uh there are general
consequences
that follow from the failure of this
proof so i think he he made a genuine
contribution
even though his his proof didn't work
and that's what i want to talk about
today
so
here's how i first became aware of it uh
i had a
an email from steve cook in
uh august 2010 to this was
to the theory group and steve said this
appears to be
a relatively serious claim to assault
people
versus np and this
paper was sent around to a lot of
big names in computer science
statistical physics
and uh finite model theory
famous logicians on on the list here so
abby victorson lassie lovash
uh dick carp uh neil emerman and so on
so you can see there's a list of very
famous names here
in the uh message
uh this this actually um got me quite
excited too
at the time because for about 10 years
i've been trying to
prove p is not equal to np using exactly
the approach
that uh diol alakar was using so this
was
um big news for me i thought oh my god
he's uh you know he's a he's uh
made a success of my favorite approach
to this problem i worked as i say i
worked for about
a decade on using this approach
basically coming from statistical
physics
but as it turned out the approach didn't
work
and i've now become convinced that no
such approach
can work and um the uh
the argument that i believe proves this
is due to ryan williams so basically
what i'm doing here
is um expanding a bit
on ryan williams basic argument from
2010.
so that's that's the upshot i think this
is actually a barrier
to proving things about
p not equal to np or p equals fp or
whatever
and so let me try and explain
what's going on here
here's the title page of of the paper i
think it's still available
online if you want to take a look at it
but
you can explain the basics of what's
going on in
in uh dale alucar's paper quite
quite shortly
so
why is this not just another proof of p
equals n p
or p not equal to np you may be aware of
this
page that's that's maintained the p
versus np page
there's about there's over a hundred
papers on here
um some serious some not so serious uh
proving that either p equals np
or p is not equal to np or
p equals np is independent of set theory
or whatever it's worth looking at it's
quite interesting
and it also has a lot of amusing stuff
on it like
homer simpson's views on p versus np
and there's also a cartoon by pavo
woodlak
on p versus np and things of that sort
but i i think most of these papers um
are you know they're not i don't think
anything followed from them
they're not worth following up on that
case it's
just basically their mistakes i think
they're just basically
somebody goofed and of course i i
imagine that at least
some of the audience here have uh proved
p
equals np or p is not equal to np or
things of that sort
um in my own case i remember prove about
20 years or ago i remember
proving p equals p space which is even
more
impressive i think you would agree um
but unfortunately of course it was a dud
but uh but uh most most of these
papers i think are not particularly
interesting
in terms of you know what followed from
them
so they were sort of sterile in that
sense but the alakar's proof
on the other hand i think was um
i think it has an interesting upshot
namely
it's not just that dale alakar's proof
was
was wrong it was incorrect
didn't work but
it uh it seems that
no such attempt as as dale alatika
attempted and that i was attempting
around
2000 to 2010 no such attempt is possibly
going to work
and that's what i want to explain
all right
so what was his approach here it is
uh i may say i think it was a very
clever
clever attempt in 2010
uh trying to prove p is not equal to np
it was based on results of
acclioptus and richie tersengi
physicist so these um these results were
inspired by statistical
physics i'll say a little bit later on
about the statistical physics
underlying it
physicist physicists got involved in
satisfiability and and related things
[Music]
because because they develop these
rather strange
method methods involving uh the
replica method which is still a rather
mysterious
subject so rather non-rigorous methods
that they developed but they they proved
all kinds of interesting things
and the results that they came up with
appeared to be
mostly correct which is rather
mysterious because the
methods were still i mean they're still
not understood
later on mathematicians and probabilists
managed to
make their results work but uh it's
still a big mystery
as to why the replica method works i
think i think this is
still an open problem some people like
michelle telegram think that
the replica method is basically just a
way of guessing at results but
i don't know i'm inclined to think
there's something there but anyway
anyway aclioptus and richie tarzangi
managed to make rigorous sense
of some of the predictions that were
made by the physicists
and dale alakar's
paper was based on their rigorous
version
of the non-rigorous results of the
physicists
all right so what what were the results
here
the results from 2006 by
aclyoptus and richie tersengi
show that if you look at an appropriate
range of clause density
the space of solutions of ksat fragments
as the unsatisfied unsatisfiable region
is approached
so you increase the number of
clauses and then you approach the
conjectured threshold
going from satisfiable to unsatisfiable
and the solution space fragments
it gets fragmented into exponentially
many fragments
and the fragments get smaller and
smaller
and so this is quite a striking
transition as you go towards
unsatisfiability
it's kind of suggests that this is the
reason
that uh sat satisfiability
the satisfiability problem is difficult
that there's this
fragmentation in the solution space
and in fact you can show this is true
for um
walks at and you know local local search
algorithms basically have trouble as you
increase the number of clauses
but dale lilachar wanted to go a bit
further what he wanted to say
was that this creates difficulties for
any possible
algorithm okay and that was my own idea
i thought that's a
this was the way to go and so i worked
for about 10 years trying to make some
sense of
of this idea
anyway dale alakar combined these
results with ideas from
finite model theory due to vardy and
immerman
to argue that this fragmentation
doesn't just rule out um
algorithms that are based on local
search but they'll rule out any
polynomial
polynomial time algorithm that was his
argument
anyway uh this paper
of the alakar was widely circulated
and he only sent it to
some big names in the complexity theory
and
logic community but but in fact it got
very widely white circulation
subsequently after it was
subjected to uh some
uh very uh difficult criticisms uh dale
alakar complained that it had been
circulated a bit too widely and he only
meant to send it to
you know a smaller group of people but
but
anyway it escaped into the wild so to
speak
and uh so the rest is history
anyway the um the circulation gave rise
to
a big discussion on the internet some of
you may remember this
uh from about uh almost 11 years ago
and uh there were a lot of um
discussion groups and mailing
mailing uh
groups that uh discussed it for example
fom i remember
discussions on fom with harvey friedman
and other people
but the most interesting discussions
were on
lipton's block goodell's lost letter in
p equals np
so here's the announcement uh from
lipton and a proof that p is not equal
to np
question mark august 8th so that's just
shortly after dale alakar sent his
paper around he describes it as a
serious proof that claims to have
resolved the p
equals np question uh rather similar to
what steve cook said
uh here's what he said he's a principal
research scientist at hp labs who's done
important research in various areas of
networks
has also worked in complexity theory
including
infinite versions of p equals np
question he's just claimed that he has a
proof that p is not equal to
mp that's right p is not equal to np
no infinite version the real deal so
that's what started the discussion off
on lipton's blog
the the discussion on the blog
incidentally is is still available on
the internet you can fish around
the discussions are very interesting and
uh
but i i don't have time to go into all
the details of them now
so the discussion on which i'm
basing my talk
there were various contributions that
were made and i think some of them were
worth talking about but the most
important criticisms i believe were made
by ken clarkson
ron fagan and ryan williams who gave a
powerpoint presentation at ibm aberdeen
and this was reported on lipton's blog
on september 15
2010.
here's the uh first slide of their
presentation okay so here it is that was
a
huge uh sensation on the internet
uh computer scientist vinay dale
claims to assault mass riddle of p
versus np
um and the new york times
said step one post elusive proof
step two watch fireworks
and uh various other things
the figaro million dollar prize has this
been resolved and so forth and so on
so this is their presentation
at ibm over then so
how do they analyze the proof here it is
uh the strategy clarkson fagin
and williams analyzed the strategy of
dale lalacare's proof as follows
first if k sat where in p
then the solution space is for all k set
formulas would have
a simple structure quote-unquote
for some k-set formulas the
solution spaces for these formulas do
not have a simple structure
that's the fragmentation that i was
talking about earlier
therefore case that's not in p and so is
p naught again
b is not equal to np okay so that's
that's the proof basically
as it's analyzed by clarkson fagan and
williams
uh clarkson and fagan make make some
very interesting
points in their presentation and other
people made very interesting criticisms
of dale alakar's paper but
the most interesting objection in my
view is the following
and i think this objection
is really deadly it goes as follows
so sat zero is this is a copy of
ryan williams slide from this
presentation by the way
sat zero objection sat zero
is formulas that are satisfied when you
set every variable to zero
okay or another way of saying it as
every clause
has a negated variable okay
and this problem is definitely in p very
easy
that's clear just need to
check the zero assignment
however we can show that for every ksat
formula
there's a sat zero formula with an
isomorphic solution space
all these distances between solutions
are preserved
okay and that's important because
the complicated structure that dale
alucar
was seeing in the sat solution space
had to do with clumps of formulas and
the distances between the clumps and
so forth and so on all distances between
solutions are preserved
so whatever complex structure you may
have in the solution space of a random
k-set formula
there are always sat zero formulas with
analogous structure
now i think this is a deadly objection
and
um
i think it's also it's also true to say
that it basically rules out
any approach to
the p equals np problem which has to do
with the complexity of the solution
space
and actually ryan williams in his
presentation
basically said this so what i'm doing
here is
i'm not being terribly original i'm just
kind of
spelling out what ryan williams said
back in 2010
um the basic idea is ryan williams i
think it's a
it's incredible it's incredible what a
simple objection it is
and yet it's i think quite far-reaching
so what i want to try and convince you
of today is that this is actually a
far-reaching
objection to an approach to p equals np
uh which in a sense uh
corresponds to a barrier in complexity
theory
similar to the ones that we face with
you know natural proofs and and
oracle results and things of that sort
okay
so that's that's the historical part of
my talk
um all of this is sort of ancient
history now but
uh i think it's worth following up a bit
in order to try to understand what's
going on here
all right so let's uh let's be a little
bit more formal
what we're talking about here is the
complementation group
basically the sat zero formulas
that that ryan williams
produces is just produced by
complementation
so if you have a couple of formulas in
kcnf
or cnf more generally then
f1 and f2 are symmetric
under the complementation group if f2
results from f1 by complementing
some of the variables in f1
for example if you take that that
formula on the left there then it's
it's equivalent to formula on the right
if you complement
p1 you complement p2 and you can
complement p23 but you leave p5 alone
okay uh
and you can also there's there's also an
additional symmetry you can
uh get f from
g from f if you get it by permuting
variables but
it's the complementation group here
that's really
important not the not the symmetry group
of
symmetrizing variables uh
it's actually a very ancient observation
in logic that
uh that there's a kind of symmetry
between
negated and unnegated variables if you
look at the early literature on
algebraic logic by john van and people
like that
back in the 19th century they were they
were quite uh
quite interested in the symmetry groups
of formulas
and uh so permuting
variables and complementing variables
was something they were very interested
in because
if you look at the two formulas that
i've written there
the equivalent formulas under the
complementation group you can see they
have
in some sense they have the same logical
form right it's sort of arbitrary
whether you write
p1 or not p1 is just
symmetrical right it's just how you
write it so
so in some sense the the two formulas
have the same logical form
and what's more important and this is
what underlies
ryan williams's original observation
uh their logical properties are
essentially the same
and then that's that's what's crucial
all right
so let's say that a property of formulas
in c and f
is symmetric if
the two formulas f if two whatever two
formulas f and g are
equivalent under the complementation
group then they have the same property
okay so you can think of this as a
structural property
right it's a structural property or a
property that
preserves logical form okay
all you're doing is complementing
variables so
basically you've kept the logical form
the same
okay you can also look at permutations
of variables but that's
that's uh that's not a major issue here
uh one thing we want to do is we want to
rewrite sat a little bit
if you look at ryan williams's original
objection
in the presentation that ibm almaden
basically he's locally he's locally
complementing the variables but
you might want to different formulas
when you when you want to rewrite a
formula
so that it's in set zero you might if
two different formulas you might want to
um you know complement variables in
different ways
so basically what we want is a
complementation operation that works
globally on sat not just locally
i think you could do put the whole
argument through if
if you were doing it locally but it's i
tried that but it's complicated so
what we want to do is rewrite sat in
such a way
that we can do this global
complementation on a set of formulas
okay so that's the next little trick
that we want to do is
it's just a little trick to make the
proof simpler
all right so suppose you've got a set of
cnf formulas so x is a set of c and
formulas
then say that this set is variable
disjoint
if whenever you've got f and g distinct
formulas
then the sets of variables variables in
f and the variables
g are disjoint okay
whenever we have such a set then we can
do a global complementation
on the set and uh that'll solve our
problem
it's easy to write rewrite
a set of c and f formulas
in this way without blowing it up too
much
so suppose you have a so there's a
family of k c and f formulas
satisfying the conditions that k
c and f to the delta so delta means
disjoint
variable disjoint
if f's in c and f then there's a formula
f to the delta m
c and f to the delta so that
this is the only place where we actually
use
variable permutation so f is
equivalent to f to the delta under
the symmetrization groups where you're
permuting variables and the function is
computable in quadratic time
none of that's very difficult it's just
a simple
simple way of
rewriting the subscripts on variables so
that you get
this disjoint this condition okay all
right so this is
a reformulation of
uh kc and f
and consequently it's np complete okay
so what what we want to do is put
through the
sat 0 objection for this
variable disjoint family okay
so what's the solution space of a
formula is just
you take the suppose you have a
formula in n variables in c and f
then the solution space for the formula
is
just this structure it's just the
boolean
hypercube and n dimensional hypercube
you've got um an edge
so this is just an edge on the hypercube
when you have
adjacent vertices and then these are the
true
these are the uh points in the hypercube
that make the formula true
okay so that's that's the solution space
uh so for sigma and tau in the hypercube
you've got e holds between sigma and if
and only if they're adjacent vertices
and uh for sigma in
the hypercube this is just the
satisfying assignments that's all
okay all right
that's the solution space
here's an example so here's this
a formula in three variables
p3 and not p1
or not p2 and the red
vertices are the ones where it's true
and the blue vertices are the ones where
it's false
okay so that's a small example of a
solution space
now let's say that the property of a
solution space is symmetric
if it's preserved under isomorphism okay
so if you have a formula in cnf
and tau belongs to the n-dimensional
hypercube then the map
which maps sigma into sigma
plus tau is an isomorphism between the
solution space
s of n of f and the solution space
s sub n of f to the tau so that's just
the formula where you
complement the variables in accordance
with the
cow in in the tile here
okay so
you got a complementation
on your hypercube and the true things
get mapped into the
uh into the true things
on the other one okay after after you do
the tau
and uh this is because the uh
satisfaction
is is an invariant under under this
isomorphism
okay and uh
you can if you have a symmetric property
of solution spaces
then the property p defined by
just the corresponding symmetric
property of the solution space is also
symmetric
okay all right
here's a little picture of an
automorphism of
hypercube
uh so here we've got the same
the same solution space that i showed
earlier on the left
and then here we
do an automorphism on the hypercube and
the true things
get mapped two strings on the right get
mapped into the two things on the left
and so on okay so obviously the two
things are
isomorphic
okay now we come to the crucial
definition
uh suppose you've got a property of sets
of c
s c and f formulas and f is a numerical
function
and x as a family of c and f formulas
there's a lower here's the definition
there's the lower bound of f
for x based on p if the following two
properties hold
first x satisfies the property p
okay and
the property forces
the any turing machine to take a lot of
time
so for any set subset of cnf
if that set has the property then
any turing machine deciding membership
in y must take
at least f of size of f
steps for infinitely many f and y okay
so this is
basically formalizing the approach
that dale alakar used as we'll see later
on there's a there's a property that he
stated
um which in this case stands in for p
which he claimed forced a
super polynomial bound
lower bound for any algorithm for sat
okay so that's his approach
all right so here's the main result it's
basically just a
um formalization of what
ryan williams said back in 2010
so uh a numerical function is super
linear
if it basically
majorizes any uh linear function
okay and here's the theorem which uh
was implicitly stated by ryan williams
so i'm not
making any great claim to originality
here here's the theorem
if p is a symmetric property of sets of
cnf formulas there's no superlinear
lower bound for sat based on b
okay using the earlier definition
so why is this true well you just
define a complementation so that for
your variable disjoint version of sat
every clause in f
with pi applied to it contains a
negative literal okay that's just the
sat zero property
right so it's in sat zero
then it's obvious that there's a linear
time algorithm for
sat to the delta so no such symmetric
property can exist
qed that's it
um it's an embarrassingly simple
proof i mean there's nothing to it right
it's just
it's just the most obvious thing i
remember when i started thinking about
sat
i noticed that you could rewrite any
satisfiable formula with this trick
to make it obvious that the thing was
satisfiable right
it's that obvious there's nothing to it
so it's an embarrassing proof in the
sense that it's so simple
but uh what ryan williams observed and
this was the really clever observation
is that it preserves all the
crucial logical properties it preserves
the solution space
okay so what does this mean means that
no symmetric property
of sets of cnf formulas can give you a
super linear lower bound it's as simple
as that
so what does this mean it means
not only that uh
the alikar's proof couldn't possibly
work
uh i'll i'll come to the details of dale
alako's proof
later because i have to convince you
that uh
the property he was using which i'll
call the dale alucar property
is symmetric but um anyway i'll come
back
back to that later okay
all right so as i said it's
it's an embarrassingly simple proof
there's really nothing to it
but um i have to convince you that it's
fairly
far-reaching um
it it's not just a question of dale
alakar's proof
and uh the proof that i had in mind
so i had i i was planning to amaze the
world with my
great uh contributions to p equals np by
by using the this sort of idea of this
you know complications of the solution
space
so that was my plan but um dale alakar
got
got ahead of me and uh it turned out his
proof was no good
but after i saw ryan williams sat sat
zero objection i realized that my entire
research project which i'd been working
on
you know like mad for 10 years was
absolute best it was no good
it's hopeless all right so
i have to convince you that that
symmetric properties is actually around
a lot of them
so let me let me spell out why this is
so
uh how am i doing on time sam
let's see you've been going for about 35
minutes
okay good okay so i i don't need to go
too slow i can speed up a little bit
okay so anyway to develop the theory of
symmetric properties
uh we'll work within the theory
theory with atoms so you take the
elements of
the hypercube as the atoms and then you
build this set theoretical hierarchy
over them
you can so when we think of the
points in the end cube in hypercube as
being
atoms then you can you can permute them
that's you can permute the uh
the vertices of the hypercube and then
you can extend it to the hierarchy of
sets defined from
from uh to the end by recursion on rank
this is this is a very old idea it goes
back to the 1920s
where franco
proved the the independence of
the acting of choice in set theory with
atoms
okay so you can you can permute the
atoms and then
you this gives you a permutation of the
entire universe
okay so starting from a solution space
which is
similar to the solution space i defined
earlier so
u is points in the hypercube e is the
adjacency
relation and t is intuitively the true
formula the true
point the the points that make the
formula true then you could define the
higher order model
constructed from s as this
universe defined over the solution space
and then you can talk about higher order
logic
language of higher order logic um
so you have a first order language
with primitive symbols membership
equality e and t where the variables
range over this
higher order universe that you defined
from u okay
now the basic point here which shows you
that there are lots and lots of
lots and lots of symmetric properties
is this the basic thing is that
if you look at permutations of
the hypercube then
a formula of higher order logic in this
set theoretical universe defined over a
set of
things in the hypercube is invariant
under
under um symmetries of the hypercube
okay so what does that tell you
uh it tells you that any definable
property of a solution space is
symmetric
it's something that ryan williams in his
original presentation hints at
but it goes a little bit further
basically any definable property
any structural or definable property of
a solution space
is symmetric okay
all right let's move on
spaces of random formulas this is just
formulas with n variables um
m clauses and k c and f
and you can define probabilities
and so on and so forth i won't go into
the details
i'm sure all of you are familiar with
the sat unsat transition there's been a
lot of work on this
alistar can ask a question sure that's
great i know you wanted to go faster
with that but space is random formulas
is this the usual computer science model
for random names
yeah yeah it's basically kc and f and
you're increasing the number of formulas
this is four sat going from left to
right and you can see there's a
transition
this peak here
represents some kind of um
i'm not quite asap it's some kind of
dpl program i'm not quite sure exactly
what it is
but as you can see there's a kind of
peak around the
peak around the threshold or the
conjectured threshold
the the existence of a of a threshold
number is has only been verified for a
high
high k but anyway um
that's not really important here it does
appear as if the hard formulas are here
at the transition
okay so what's the dale alakar property
i'm not going to give a precise
definition of it because
uh i can give a precise definition but
it would
result in a completely unreal unreadable
slide
so it says
that with high probability a random
formula
in n variables and rn clauses
satisfies the following conditions the
family
of true satisfying points in the
solution space consists of
exponentially many regions each with
small diameter
and separated from other regions by a
large distance okay
and uh for sufficiently large k
in every cluster of the true
points almost all variables are frozen
which is to say
they take the same value throughout the
cluster okay
and as you approach the conjectured
threshold
as you approach the threshold the
clusters get smaller and smaller and
they get further apart
and it looks more and more like an error
correcting code in fact
is is what's going on here okay
another question here alistair yes is k
the clause size
uh k is the cost size yes thank you yes
k is the class
right thank you all right so that here's
a picture
of how things evolve so below the
threshold we've got this big clump
and then at some point there's a phase
transition
and it breaks up the clump breaks up and
then
each clump gets smaller and smaller and
gets
further and further apart and uh things
get more and more frozen
okay that's the uh that's the picture
okay as i said there's a there's a
precise definition but i won't go into
it it just
would be a completely unreadable slide
okay so the basic result here and this
is the result
that dale lalakar was depending on
is that the family cnf satisfies a
precisely formulated version of the
property d
as i said i'm not going to give the
precise formulation and this is the main
result
of a paper by acclioptus
demetrius aclioptus and ricci terzengia
who's a physicist
okay a very a very nice paper by the way
a beautiful paper
and they provided a precise version
of rigorous version of what the
physicists had
conjectured all right why is this
symmetrical
well it's symmetric because when it's
formulated rigorously
you can see see that the key properties
are formulated in this higher order
logic i was
talking about earlier so they're all
symmetric the key properties are all
symmetric
so by the earlier theorem that i stated
which is
basically g to ryan williams d
can be used to prove a super lower
linear bound for sat
okay uh and dela lalakar's proof broke
down when he tried to prove his
so the the stuff of uh acclioptus and
richie tarzani is all perfectly fine but
he broke his proof broke down when you
tried to prove a super linear lower
bound
from the property d as observed by neil
limberman
here's neil uh
in the physicist's approach uh you can
also talk about the
i'm not going to talk about the
physicist's approach very much here
if you're given a cn formula in
n variables the energy of an assignment
is defined as the number of clauses
not satisfied by phi
okay an assignment
and then the the energy landscape of a
formula
like the solution space is a symmetric
form function of of f
notice this is this the energy landscape
gives you a lot more
information than the solution
the solution space right you know how
many clauses are
satisfied and unsatisfied and so on so
it's there's a lot of
information here but it's a symmetric
function
so approaching
sat through the energy landscape is also
hopeless in the sense that
as long as the properties that you use
to show that p is not equal to np or
whatever
as long as it's definable in this higher
order logic
that you've defined over
over your your uh solution space or your
energy landscape or whatever
can't be used to prove a super linear
lower band
percent this is simply because
definable properties are symmetric end
of story
uh there is something extra you can say
though
uh namely no symmetric property can rule
out all
polynomial time algorithms for sat
however for particular proof system
uh you can show that there are symmetric
properties of cnf formulas that can be
shown
to show large advisor proof systems and
so for algorithms based on those proof
systems for example resolution
and there's something more general you
can say here
if you have
if you have a an algorithm where
the the no instances
you look at the um you look at the look
at the computation
of for a no instance if there's no
instance
can be uh verified
by a symmetric proof system
then there are then if you can show a
lower bound at all
then you can show it using a symmetric
property okay
and lots of proof systems are symmetric
for example fragra systems
they're symmetric you can just flip a
and not a and you get you know same
lower bounds
so it seems to be that the following is
possible that although there's no
symmetric property that rules out
all polynomial algorithms it's
conceivable that for any particular
algorithm there is a symmetric property
that provides you with a lower bound
i think that's quite conceivable but
anyway that's just
that's just my conjecture and
probably i should stop there thank you
okay all right
thank you very much alistair very
interesting let me clap on everybody's
behalf
i think you can't all do it um we have
some time for questions
uh so we can take as much time as we
need really so
please either talk into the chat window
or just speak up
and again if someone wants to be
promoted please just raise your hand
um can i ask a question
yeah thank you so much also that was
very very interesting and
bring up memories but i wonder about the
thing that you said at the end that
both systems are symmetric um
i'm having a hard time of thinking of a
proof system that's not symmetric do you
have an example
oh i didn't say all proof systems are
symmetric uh i just said that some of
the
best known proof systems such as
resolution and
resolution is obviously symmetric and
fragrance systems are also
symmetric but no i i don't claim that
all proof systems are symmetric
definitely not
so is there an example of a pro system
that's not symmetric
well suppose p is not equal to np
uh then uh we can certainly say
i think we can say that uh if we think
of the algorithm as being a proof system
um then that would not be a symmetric
uh proof system i think so um i don't
know of an example of hand
a well-known proof system but a lot of
well-known proof systems are symmetric
that's all i can say
well take a somewhat trivial example if
you just took
uh the method of truth truth tables and
took the solutions in lexigraphic order
or something like that
that would be symmetric yeah yeah thank
you so much thank you
so much oh yeah thank you yeah it's a
good example
which interestingly enough we have
well-known
exponential or balance for trivially
you're right
that was it okay um all right
um oliver wanted to ask a question
i've heard if you have a question okay
hello alice good to see very good
i just wanted uh to better understand
range of the argument since it's yet
very fuzzy to me i
must admit um okay um
invariance under isomorphism that's most
that's the most basic
assumption in mathematics and thus one
doesn't work without
a notion which is not in the invariant
and isomorphism is no good notion
roughly of course but especially in
certain circles of mathematics
and and let's say um
every we assign uh two
um to any boolean formula uh the
shortest circuit size
and if we do the definition in the right
way then this is
definitely symmetric uh the the names of
the variables and the name
and the indications so
and then we prove um
whatever so so so every mathematical
function will be finally not depending
on the representation
on the accidents
of the representation actually at least
one would think so right
well and i said so a lower bound on that
complexity function that's
that was that's what you want and then
finally if uh sure
so so therefore i of course it's
something else so you're you were
discussing about the property not this
function so i said
there's a difference but i cannot really
could you explain it a little bit
better to me or perhaps
if you understand what my problem is
uh sorry uh say again oliver what were
you saying
so so it seems for me um
every function every property must be
symmetric otherwise it's not
mathematical
and
well
[Music]
yeah i understand what you're saying
there but uh
i think that's yeah i mean
it's plausible to say that that
mathematical properties are
are symmetric or or structural or
something like that
and if you look at say graph theory then
a lot of the properties that get
discussed in graph theory
are symmetric in the sense that
they um they apply to unlabeled graphs
right and
what you're saying is true in general
but what what
ryan williams's argument says
essentially that if you're going to
prove
p is not equal to np by using some
property
of you know sat then it can't be a
symmetric property that's that's
essentially what uh ryan williams's uh
observation
says
[Music]
and i mean you know is that a
mathematical property well who knows
maybe there's a mathematical
property in some broader sense i don't
know anyway
thank you so i've i have to think about
it so perhaps yeah okay
sure
it has to do with the representation of
of the the formula i agree
and in general when you're thinking
about logic you don't care whether it's
p
or not p as i said you know you can
complement the variables and and
you get essentially the same logical
formula
and uh has the same logical properties
the solution space is isomorphic and so
forth and so on
and that's exactly essentially why the
argument works
and in the case of resolution too let's
think about resolution
or other proof systems
that's a symmetric proof system you can
flip around
p and not p and you can still prove the
same lower bounds it's
invariant property the lower bounds
they're invariant under complementation
but it wasn't your argument not focused
on satisfiable instances that you can
always morph
any satisfaction in a trivially
satisfied instance
but but you can't do anything with
unsatisfiable instances
no you just leave them alone
that's why i had the same question as
by the way thank you for your wonderful
talk this is
here um but i had a similar question to
oliver's
you started by talking about symmetric
properties of solution spaces
right and at some point you made a
transition to
properties definable in some higher
order logic and then you had a lump
that says all properties and that are
definable in this logic are symmetric
so therefore if and then you made a
transition to
proof systems and i quite didn't
understand that bit
oh yes sorry i i was rather hurrying at
the end but
basically what i was trying to say in
the last
slide or second to last slide was
that although there's no symmetric
properties that rules out all polynomial
time algorithms are said
for particular polynomial time
algorithms
such as resolution-based algorithms for
example
uh there are such symmetric properties
which show that this particular
algorithm
um fails in the sense that it
has to be super linear or super
polynomial rather that's
that was the point i was making excuse
me there
i think i understand what you mean by
symmetric properties of solution spaces
and from that the leap to symmetric
properties of proof systems
do you mean that um
yeah i'm not quite sure what you need
symmetric properties of proof
systems meaning that the lower bound
okay no i was talking about symmetric
proof systems so for example take a
resolution proof
and complement all the you know
complement the variables arbitrarily
it's still a resolution proof
okay yeah the same is true for phrega
systems
you can complement take a frag of proof
and complement the variables arbitrarily
it's still a fragrant proof makes no
difference
it's it's symmetric in that sense okay
so a symmetric proof system
is one where you take a proof take a
proof
complement the variables arbitrarily
it's still a proof
okay right and that's true for phryga
systems so if you have a
a um i mean we don't have lower bounds
for
fraga based proof systems if we did
this would be a very powerful result but
we don't have roller bands for fraga
systems except for very easy
lower bounds but
if we did have such lower bounds then we
would have symmetric properties that
prove such lower bands that's the point
i'm making
is this true for all proof systems that
are closed under restriction
like fragile systems um
it's just re-labeling you just relabel
the variables that's
all uh restriction yeah
restriction is yeah well
it's just relabeling that's all it is
you're just rewriting the proof
complementing the variables that's all
that's that's all you're doing so that's
true for fragrance systems
and so
if there are if there were a lower bound
for sat
for fraga based algorithms
okay then there would be a symmetric
property that shows that
that's the point
okay
that makes sense good
any more questions um
i guess i maybe had a very just a short
question um since the symmetries are
sort of you're looking at the
symmetries of the solution space can be
gleaned by looking at the
true truth table the function obviously
is and the same holds for the arguments
based on its natural proofs which take
the truth table the function
is there any connection between natural
proofs and these symmetry
very good question i have no idea
maybe i should look at that but uh yeah
that's a very good question uh i i
should think about that thank you
okay good any other questions
um just a very naive question also about
symmetrical system
oh so
if p is not equal in p is it possible to
say
that um no optimal
proof system can be symmetric or
something along those lines
of approaches can be used as a way to
get some kind of lower balance
good question i don't know the answer i
was just trying to argue that
it's quite conceivable that
see that it's a quantifier shift um
there doesn't exist a symmetric property
that shows lower bounds
for sat in the way that i defined it but
then on the other hand for a given proof
system
there might be such or even a family of
proof systems there might be such
a symmetric property so it's you're
shifting the quantifiers around here
i don't know the answer to your question
about optimal proof systems
it's actually a very good question so
sorry i don't know
i think if there is an optimal proof
system then there's one that's symmetric
because you could always compose an
optimal proof system
with a symmetry operation on the
variables first
that sounds plausible which doesn't
change that's my building yeah i haven't
i actually haven't thought about optimum
processing
thank you that's very cool thing okay
okay last call for questions thank you
for all the discussion
um i don't see any things chat windows
all right
thank you again aleister for a very
interesting welcome
yeah very nice and uh we have a
fellows talk in about 20 minutes if you
want if you guys are interested in that
but uh
for now it's a goodbye for this week and
thank you again
alistair thank you soon
thanks for the nice talk